[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a revista digital
donde abordamos los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa la noticia sobre
la condena de dos jóvenes influencers en
egipto le dio la vuelta al mundo por las
condiciones del caso ambas fueron
declaradas culpables de tráfico de
personas por invitar a sus seguidores a
monetizar sus contenidos en redes
sociales pero este no es el único país
donde se han presentado casos en los que
apelando a la moralidad se han judicial
izado a creadores de contenido bajo
leyes que son consideradas como ambiguas
por parte de activistas de derechos
humanos quienes denuncian que las
mujeres se ven más afectadas empezamos
cunningham y mahuad al adham dos de las
jóvenes influencers más populares de
egipto fueron declaradas culpables del
delito de tráfico de personas por
invitar a sus seguidores a monetizar el
contenido que publican en sus redes
sociales ambas junto a otros tres
hombres acusados de ayudarlas habían
sido detenidos y sentenciados a dos años
de cárcel el año pasado por promover la
inmoralidad y violar los valores
familiares egipcios
concretamente vaguada había sido
declarada culpable de compartir fotos y
vídeos que calificaron como indecentes
con los más de un millón de seguidores
que tiene en instagram mientras que hang
in por haber publicado un vídeo
explicando cómo hacer dinero a través
del streaming en la plataforma de vídeos
like y un tribunal de apelaciones anuló
el fallo en enero pero la fiscalía los
acusó de tráfico de personas por lo que
ahora fueron sentenciados a penas de
entre 6 y 10 años de prisión a través de
su cuenta de instagram y desde donde
ahora sólo sigue al presidente egipcio
abdel fattah al cis y janine publicó un
vídeo antes de su arresto pidiendo ayuda
al mandatario
las reacciones contra las sentencias a
estas dos jóvenes se han dejado ver en
redes sociales donde han promovido
campañas a favor de su liberación
los mensajes se mueven bajo los
numerales liberen a janine y liberen a
mahuad a los usuarios han vuelto a ser
viral un hashtag escrito en árabe que
significa con el permiso de la familia
egipcia una especie de sátira contra los
enjuiciamientos por los delitos de
violación a los valores de la familia o
incitación a la inmoralidad cargos que a
opinión de organizaciones defensoras de
derechos humanos se utilizan para
perseguir a chicas jóvenes por el simple
hecho de publicar un vídeo bailando o
cantando en plataformas como tick tock
se estima que otras siete mujeres han
sido arrestadas en el país desde 2020
bajo estas justificaciones
este tipo de cargos relacionados con la
moralidad y los valores familiares están
enmarcados en una serie de disposiciones
de una ley de ciberdelitos aprobada en
2018 activistas y organizaciones
defensoras de derechos humanos señalan
que esta legislación es ambigua y que da
a las autoridades judiciales amplios
poderes para procesar a los usuarios en
redes sociales por varias causas crítica
que no sólo limita la libertad de
expresión sino que se usa de manera
desproporcionada contra las mujeres así
también lo describió a male elsa danny
directora legal y judicial del instituto
tahrir para políticas de medio oriente
una ong con sede en washington
les creó una parte de la historia tiene
que ver con la economía que estas
mujeres que son de diferentes clases
socioeconómicas estén siendo judicial
izadas por el régimen para monetizar
'tik tok' y like y haciendo dinero en
una forma a la que quizás el régimen no
se estaba beneficiando o recibiendo
impuestos
este es un ángulo significativo para
entenderlo esta clase de habilidad de
las mujeres de generar ingresos a partir
de ello que es completamente legal y
completamente permitido en muchos países
es amenazante para muchos
porque eso representa independencia
si bien esta serie de situaciones se han
hecho más visibles en egipto durante el
último año no son exclusivas de este
país un gran ejemplo es el caso de la
instaura que fue conocida en el mundo
como la angelina jolie de irán llamada
así por el parecido que muchos le
encontraban con la actriz
shahar está bar se hizo popular en 2017
por las fotografías que publicaba en
redes sociales y en las que lucía un
rostro completamente distorsionado
aunque primero se dijo que era producto
de decenas de cirugías la joven confesó
que en realidad había usado maquillaje y
editor de fotos sus publicaciones le
salieron caras y en 2019 fue arrestada y
acusada de varios cargos entre ellos
blasfemia alentar a los jóvenes a la
corrupción y obtener ingresos por medios
inapropiados
un año después fue sentenciado a 10 años
de prisión y en diciembre de 2020 se
conoció que había sido puesta en
libertad bajo fianza para mí el saddam y
estas son tácticas típicas de regímenes
autoritarios
tiene menos que ver con religión pero si
de la naturaleza autoritaria de
gobiernos que frecuentemente están
instrumentalizando
o usando la religión y el
conservadurismo para construir un
argumento para sí mismos para ello no se
trata de que sean religiosos no se trata
de religión o de una comprensión
inapropiada de ésta sino más bien como
ellos pueden consolidar el control y
desafortunadamente la religión es a
menudo una excusa que se usa no solo en
medio oriente sino en todo el mundo
y la gran mayoría de medios de
comunicación alrededor del mundo han
registrado la noticia enfocándose en la
pena por tráfico de personas contra
estas jóvenes pero otros han destacado
los problemas que esto supone para los
influences nada más el medio de
comunicación independiente de egipto
titula heart in hosam arrestada después
de un vídeo emotivo mientras grupos de
derechos humanos condenan las duras
penas de prisión contra los creadores de
contenido en eeuu del portal de training
beast dice tick tock era detenida en
egipto por llevar las mujeres a unirse a
las redes sociales el periódico de
catalunya titula egipto encarcela a 2
dictó crees por tráfico de personas
en su ofensiva contra la libertad de las
mujeres la revista semanal francesa
cookie internacional titula egipto la
cacería de chicas de 'tik tok' y otras
personas influyentes y añade que ser una
mujer joven con millones de seguidores
en las redes sociales en egipto puede
resultar muy caro
hasta aquí revista digital recuerde que
si quieren repetir esta u otra emisión
de nuestro programa lo puede hacer a
través de nuestra página web www puntos
24 punto com
[Música]